la municipalité souhaite expérimentée
une nouvelle approche pour lutter contre
les rats n'allez pas à Marseille
d'ailleurs Mathieu ils ont décidé de
recruter des furets
visiblement ça marche de ouf je vous dis
plusieurs villes françaises ont déjà
réalisées expérience on a une vidéo
récap qui va tout vous expliquer
apparemment il y aura Tim furetima ok
voilà Tim furet timbra voilà les furets
apparemment vont venir attaquer les rats
donc là ils ont ouvert une école de
furet qui fait des arts martiaux toute
la journée voilà tu vois ils sont quand
même
ils sont sur entraînés
Krav Maga et les souris voilà donc
je vous le dis c'est non mais sans
régler c'est la faute de fou si vous en
croisez un agissez pas seul voilà
regardez c'est incroyable
les rap peuvent parfois être un
véritable fléau les rats les souris
maintenant ils en ont plus rien à [ __ ]
à Marseille la ville compte même 1,5 rap
par habitant alors pour les éradiquer la
cité phocène a eu une idée des furets
pour venir à bout des rats à Marseille
habile ses petites bêtes peuvent se
faufiler chasser les rats pour les
piégés dans un filet bon je vais la
mettre à travailler alors la méthode
va-t-elle porter ses fruits
l'expérimentation devrait commencer à la
mi-décembre
alors
les chéris est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire Gilles Verdez tu as enquêté là
dessus qu'est-ce qui va se passer parce
que ça s'intéresse vraiment toutes les
personnes qui nous regardent et moi
notamment moi je suis à fond sur les
rats actuellement vous le savez que je
suis voilà je prépare une thèse voilà
sur les rats et les furets apparemment
ils savent comment attaquer les rats et
comment les éradiquer parce que les
furets s'éduquent et il y a deux
éleveurs du Gers qui ont éduqué les
furets d'accord pour que les furets
chassent les rats c'est le Seigneur des
furets ça veut dire donc il lui
remontera ça pas bien oui le rappeur de
l'odeur du furet donc les furets
arrivent un groupe de furets arrivent
deux ou trois par exemple
ils arrivent c'est quoi il faut qu'il
soit de bonne humeur parce que le furet
peut dormir 20h par jour non mais
90 minutes enquêtes sur les furets nous
avons suivi une bande de furets
Toulouse et à Vitry-sur-Seine
d'accordier quoi
il y avait des rats et maintenant il y a
des furets exactement en banlieue
parisienne à Vitry-sur-Seine ils sont
remontés par le chantier du Grand Paris
envahiturer mais comment on va y avoir
mais comment comment non mais les gars
ils arrivent comment ils arrivent comme
ça ils sont dans un camion ils ouvrent
et là les purées
sur l'île de la tentation ils arrivent
en zodiaque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas être partout non plus les
habitants des furets les éleveurs
vont chasser les rats dans les filets et
oui les rats vont avoir peur de l'odeur
du furet donc il faut lire le furet ça
pue il existe vraiment de furet c'est
insupportable alors donc maintenant on a
plus grand mais les véhicules
dans deux semaines ils vont envoyer des
blaireaux pour chasser les furex
et il est
[Rires]
comme il y a des filets il les récupère
et ce qui est moins drôle c'est une
erreur
dans les filets et après les hommes les
tuent avec du gaz carbonique en fait ah
d'accord il y a pas de bagarre
parce que ça évite les saloperies de
pièges qui sont voilà c'est le furet à
Manu qui va repousser les rats d'accord
le furet il arrive comme ça
genre il part de chez lui mais c'est
Granger
ce soir
[Rires]
alors oui les nouveaux combats les
écolos après ça va être maintenant les
pigeons c'est de nouveau problème ils
sont en train d'enlever tous les petits
pics que tu vois sur les monuments et
tout ça également sur les balcons tout
ça parce que ça tue les animaux donc qui
ont enlevé tous les petits pics donc il
va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup plus de
pigeons qu'avant et de fientes de
pigeons donc c'est un problème pour le
tourisme mais les écolos sont très donc
le prochain après les rats le prochain
combat à Paris ça va être les pigeons là
quand tu marcheras tu auras une chance
sur deux de t'en prendre une de quoi de
prendre un pigeon de prendre un pigeon
une viande de pigeon absolument
ils peuvent se mettre n'importe où et
qui sont plus chasser mais ils vont
venir à Paris plutôt qu'en fait le
pigeon voilà va exactement d'accord donc
les pigeons haut les ras en bas les fur
et à côté
c'est la folie